all right let's jump to this first story
from the national post
jordan peterson suspended from twitter
says it might as well be a ban because i
won't apologize quote if i can't be let
back on because i won't apologize i
could care less jordan peterson told the
national post if twitter suspended his
account over a tweet about elliot page i
don't think jordan peterson said
anything about elliot page he's not no
he was referring to an ellen page
on june 28 the controversial author i
like how they say he's controversial
clinical psychologist and professor
emeritus at the university of toronto
lost access to most of his twitter
account features because of a tweet he
posted earlier in the week that used
transgender actor elliot page's former
name and suggested he had his breasts
removed by a criminal physician
so that he said quote i penned an
irritated tweet in response to one of
the latest happenings on the
increasingly heated culture war front
peter told the national post
as far as peterson is concerned the
temporary suspension might as well have
been a ban because he would rather die
than delete the tweet in question he
said it does the tweet stay up when it
happens i think so i'm going to check it
out
private i think
it's private they want you to be the one
to take it down to admit you're wrong
which is psychologically manipulative
that's a very psychological move it's
like no one can see it
but you have to remove it yourself like
we could remove it but you have to do it
or you're you can't come back
very interesting
yeah yeah like making a kid go out into
the woods and pick his own switch yeah
it is very much
yes but i think it's a legal thing i
think it's a legal thing is it yeah i
think they're like we can't reliability
yeah like we can't we can't remove it
because then we are directly involved or
something like that also then where's
the proof
if you're like hey where's your proof
that i violated terms there's nothing up
right but then there's also i mean like
facebook's removed all sorts of stuff
i've put up over the years and i'm sure
twitter has actually been fairly good to
me on most stuff but but in terms of i
mean i think they can remove stuff but
maybe only if it's like you said
violating the terms and if this is
something that doesn't technically
violate their terms they're like okay
well we're just going to make you remove
it i'm honestly not sure what it is i it
also might be because he's so prominent
they don't want to remove it they want
him to remove it and make that you know
like atonement for it i honestly don't
know if this was a small account they
would have gotten they just yeah get
nuked yeah yeah yeah
but i think the principal issue as to
why he got suspended was because he said
criminal he's a criminal physician i
think is what he said right is that what
he said what's his exact tweet physician
right and that's it right there the
insinuation of a crime or something is
probably why they took it down oh dead
naming yeah yeah not dead naming no no
policy um
i don't know i i i issued a tweet like
so so often when people get suspended
for stuff like this i will tweet
something out similar in the same vein
but specifically like jumping over the
landmines of the rules yeah so that i
can effectively say something similar
but to prove a point kind of just like
make make the point yeah i didn't get
suspended maybe maybe i don't knock on
wood spoke too soon but after i heard
that jordan peterson got suspended i
tweeted who is ellen page and what does
breast removed mean yeah so by posing it
as a question the issue is with you know
youtube and other all these platforms
they don't want you attacking people
that's the real issue
they don't mind you criticizing people
but
what twitter youtube these other
platforms have said you know behind the
scenes or i mean actually they say it
overtly is their goal is a healthier
conversation
so if you're being critical of someone
but you're doing it calmly they're fine
with it but if you start calling names
and stuff then that's when they so you
think it was more about the
the criminal accusation than about uh
calling uh elia ellen
it's it's it's it's kind of vague but
the idea is
these big social media platforms they
don't want to cultivate a culture around
everyone throwing rocks and mud at each
other right so i talked to google
and they told me because like you know
we have google partners i actually know
a ton people work at google and they
said we're trying to just clamp down on
people who are angry nasty people who
make their shows based on just
being nasty and mean right and they were
like obviously your show is nothing like
that so you have nothing to worry about
and i was like
i mean i don't believe you uh to be
completely honest but i appreciate you
said that to me right right just as a
side note i looked up the terms of
service or twitter and it says they do
prohibit targeting others with repeated
slurs tropes other content that intends
to humanize degrade or reinforce
negative harmful stereotypes this
includes targeted misgendering or dead
naming so i think that might have been
what did that might have been it not
sure or might even both yeah
so
if you're a small account on twitter you
get no benefit of the doubt right of
course they just nuke you in two seconds
i don't care for jordan peterson
if if if the you know the crim putting
criminal in there i think is what put
him over the edge of there they're
saying like you're you're attacking
you're you know being mean and nasty or
something like that yeah yeah yeah i
don't think it was a dead naming it
probably played a role probably couldn't
help but i don't think jordan peterson
knows who elliott paige is or anything
about that you know what i mean right i
think he just saw something it was like
i can't believe they did this what i'm
gonna tweet about it it's a criminal and
then they're like you're gone yeah yeah
so that it might have been the the dead
naming that got their attention
but the you know the letter of the rule
that was broken was the criminal
accusation yeah here's an interesting
question right
it is true that for a while
youtube twitter and facebook and big
social media platforms we're seeing a
lot of people become very prominent off
of just being really nasty
now the problem is the left is still
extremely nasty and they get away with
it all the time
so
i recognize it's a problem my problem is
like maybe you guys should
actually actually do something to to
calm people down and foster healthier
conversations instead of just banning
conservatives
yeah
this is why last night we talked about
christianity i brought up like the cult
of christianity i think when you're
criticizing a cult
it's different than criticizing the
individuals if you're criticizing the
tenets of a cult like the transgender
ideologies of like i was born in a male
body but i want to call myself a woman
now if you question that that's really
not a big problem if you go after the
individuals that are experiencing it
then you're on hot water like he brought
up ellen's or elliot's name ellen page
elliot page and now that's like yo now
you're
bringing someone into it an innocent
bystander almost a part someone that's
part of it yeah i think there's
something to be said a difference
between someone giving their in their
mind principle take either way on the
transgender debate or discussion and
like for example on the on the anti side
you know going after you know making fun
of suicide rates or something and you
know uh going after individual people
with memes about suicide or something
like that that goes over the line of
having a discussion about their
disagreement with the idea of gender not
being tied to biological sex and
actually saying well i'm going to attack
this person so that would be an example
of that and obviously there are other
examples on the other side as well but
you know it's the difference between
having even a heated debate and going at
someone personally like you said to your
point attacking them well here's here's
an issue
jordan peterson has a lot of very very
important things to say
least of which is his comments about
elliott page right
should he
just say fine delete the tweet so he can
carry on saying the more important
things to his 2.8 million followers this
is this is the challenge i think jordan
should probably set up a truth social
account or something where he can tweet
all day about these ideas right but not
give up the battlefield over this one
thing
it's it's tough isn't it that's a
judgment call for him to make he has to
it really comes down to he has to decide
how important what he was trying to say
in that tweet was right like is that
worth giving that up and it's not just
what's in that tweet but the idea of
something that jordan peterson has said
a lot is uh i'm not going to say uh
something that i don't agree with just
because it'll make things easier so if
that's you know the hill he's willing to
die on even if it's not necessarily in
and of itself that important he may back
away from the whole thing and that's you
know
i'm not even saying that that's that i
agree with with that decision being made
but you know he's the one that built
that platform or built that audience and
it was on that kind of principle so it's
it's a tough it's a judgment call man
like if he asked me what would i what
should i do i'm not sure i'd have a good
answer for him it feels like
a metaphor for this would be or some
kind of example
jordan peterson they swept the leg
they knocked him down and he says you're
not supposed to sweep the leg so i'm
done i'm done fighting and it's like
whoa whoa whoa whoa you didn't lose
the fight's still happening yeah don't
walk away just because they pulled a
cheap shot right get up and try and win
and so the concern i have here is i get
that it was bad that they're censoring
him he should be allowed to express
these ideas they should not be censored
but if jordan peterson has a million
important things to say and one of them
got him knocked down
it's not only did he say it
what he said has been blasted off a
million fold everyone's seen it yeah
it's it's been seen substantially more
than ever before and you can say i got
my message out there let's get back to
work yeah so that that's that's the
challenge with the censorship issue is
everybody's saying like we shouldn't be
on youtube and i'm like retreat from the
battlefield so that we can go into a
high school parking lot and talk to no
one yeah or recognize there are certain
things that will get us kicked off the
battlefield and we got to fight with
with what you know space we have yeah
and then we set up the timcast.com you
know members only show so that we can
try and still do this we are working on
stuff behind the scenes in terms of
infrastructure just we can only go as
fast as humans can go but hopefully
we'll have some big announcements coming
soon and um
i think i i kind of feel like
jordan's made his point he can come back
on twitter and he can start smack
talking again you should go for it i
think you made a good point spike that
he's made kind of his career around her
a big part of his career is like i'm not
gonna use compel you cannot compel me to
say something i don't believe and in
this situation i think
if he did recant and say okay fine all
right fine i'll do whatever you want
i'll bend the knee that he'll lose 40 30
of his followers or like they'll just
lose faith in him and right now he's got
the faith of humanity on his side so
wherever he goes whatever he does people
will listen people will follow he he
also could be um playing the long game
of expecting elon musk to purchase
twitter so he can come back triumphant
however many weeks months from now and
say see look i didn't i didn't bend i
said what i said and i'm not going to
back off and you know you can take that
to the bank that i'll never back off of
of something that i believe um and you
know if that ends up if that ends up
playing out that way then uh he ended up
playing a much longer game than the rest
of us here's an idea he can uh take his
tweet down and then ish and then as soon
as his account is reopened issue a new
tweet saying follow me on truth social
because screw this platform they're
censorious
trying to pull as many of their users
off the platform as possible to make
them suffer yeah that's one way to do it
i mean look if jordan peterson's saying
he's going to nuke he's never coming
back to twitter it's like all right give
give him one one final show
come back on and be like come on
everybody parties out here let's get out
of here and delete your own account and
then or you just put a bit if you want
to see what jordan peters say here's the
link to truth social yeah yeah that's
that's the way you got to do it do minds
truth socials
trump will ban you for talking crap
about them on social media that's true i
have to give a shout out to my friend
reid coverdale because what he does is
whenever a new you know so-called free
speech platform comes out he immediately
goes on creates an account and says a
bunch of stuff that that you know takes
conservatives off and so you know
immediately go on there and be like you
know i i'm not even sure if i should say
this stuff because we're streaming on
youtube but uh saying a bunch of various
things that might uh uh tick people off
on the center right and see how quickly
it takes him to get kicked off and it's
usually measured in minutes or hours um
and uh and so he says you know these
typically and i'm not sure about truth
social uh particularly but in general um
any of these things it's typically it's
more not necessarily free speech
in in
entirely but more conservative friendly
speech as opposed to the other the
twitter version where it's more
progressive or centrist friendly speech
um he has a he has a so far uh he's
batting a thousand for getting knocked
off these platforms shout out to reed
coverdale yes nice job thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you